en fait l'avenir voilà
salut les gars comme ça ça je voulais
sas est intransférable
c'est un lionel messi ya beaucoup de
chaînes qui m'ont rappelé sa part pas il
ya même la chaîne météo
pour vous ils m'ont appelée chasse et
pêche wayne on m'appelle beaucoup pour
vous sachez un considérable bachelot
vient enfin son bébé ça va être un
succès tu peux me tutoyez aujourd'hui on
est dans une france où tout le monde se
tutoie commandant d accord
cette semaine c'est le début de la
semaine et on parle quoi au début cette
semaine
ah oui d'accord exactement et la semaine
dernière dans tes paper a pris plein les
mirettes
attention ça fait un an je suis bon un
petit un petit goût mais allez-y merci
alors ça c'est magnifique c'est tout je
peux pas dire la main ces eaux qui vient
des volcans ça mais c'est bio c'est bien
mais comme ta gueule ou épicés lente
alors vous avez dit [ __ ] dans mes bras
mais si c'est ça c'est parti pour le zap
noda et la semaine dernière c'était le
grand autour de daniel moreau qui avait
plein de choses à nous raconter ou
tonetto sentimentale ne s'est pas vu
depuis un petit moment mince a pas
changé mais heureusement que bernard
montiel est là pour lui donner des
petits conseils et tout plein de
bienveillance en fut l'un des
conseillers du milieu d'abord c'est
qu'il se trouverait pousse à aimer c'est
pour ça mais lourd
petit conseil cycliste de cas adoré
l'invité du jour nadège beausson-diagne
chat sexisme et que sexisme vous n'étiez
pas comme ça mais c'est vrai c'est
honteux bernard à les séries et on
compte sur vous pour relever le niveau y
en a bien un qui va vous l'amour qu'on a
envie de le conduire
babès kerviel s'est parlé de son fils
mais c'est important de bien comprendre
de quoi parle le film le regardait
tranquillement narmer acadienne y a
plein d'amis à moi des tunisiens qui
m'ont dit quoi ces meurtres en cayenne
en porsche cayenne
ça n'a rien à voir en tout cas niveau
audience cyril vous avez fait une jolie
promesse 6 à 2,5 millions je prends son
slip et je fais des missions exclusives
sur la tête
c'est une idée elle est passée à sa d'un
joli petit slip sur la tête puisque ça
fait 4 8 millions alors le slip normes
et vous avez pas un truc
regardez
et après cayenne on termine par les
maldives parce que benjamin castaldi
connais bien même si vous avez
complètement fut fort et ses plans je
crois que benjamin castaldi de partir
aux maldives sont novatrices pour sa
femme
j'ai une surprise contre al massa n'est
plus c'est dommage spacieux castaldi se
voyait déjà bien sûr la plage en train
de faire du topless plus montré mission
s'interdit à l'occuper la wii le slip et
là exactement c'est vrai alors c'est le
style de vie quoi ces lois jim attendu
jeu le mode quand même s'il n'en fait
pas attention j'ai des poils pubiens sur
la tête ce week-end pour jouer au tennis
non vraiment le mien bat artois
l'émission site est devenu tunisiens
défiler jeudi soir cette école banderas
sera à vendre après les tp est également
exact avait multitude d'émissions et je
l'entends dire ah j'ai pas vu un ça j'ai
loupé d'un dommage parce qu'il s'est
passé plein de trucs
on a découvert que valérie bénaïm savez
compter jusqu'à pas joli mal à supporter
qui a préparé bien sa galère vous pas
facile aussi
cyril encourage à aller chez lui tard
daniel c on a vu jean mis à boire un
verre et je passais grosse merde il
aboie un verre et non pascal boisvert
on l'a vu gilles verdez jouer à chat
perché gagner au nez a eu droit une
peinture personnalisée pour sa voiture
et apparemment il a d'autres
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et tout ce qui m'intéresse premier c'est
la peinture de sa voiture mais c'était
sans compter isa la folle du volant qui
va engloutir non pas une fois mais trois
fois
en tout cas nous on a passé une super
soirée pas vrai maloche tiens ta gueule
merci merci merci
[Applaudissements]